aujourd'hui j'ai envie de vous donner
des conseils à quel moment je dois
stopper une course si d'éventuelles
douleurs apparaissent
[Musique]
et bien c'est très simple si jamais
pendant que vous êtes en train de courir
vous avez la tête qui tourne une
sensation d'ivresse si jamais vous avez
le palpitant qui s'emballe de fortes
douleurs thoraciques si jamais vous avez
des sueurs froides par exemple là il
faut stopper ensuite les douleurs elles
peuvent être d'origine articulaires dans
les membres inférieurs
par exemple une douleur qui apparaît au
genou si elle persiste si elle ne passe
pas il faut arrêter sinon vous pouvez
aggravé une éventuelle blessure d'ordre
musculaire maintenant si jamais vous
avez soudainement une douleur très vive
et un cap à 601 incapacitantes là il
faut arrêter
si par exemple c'est un claquage vous
n'allez faire qu'empirer les choses
et tout de suite après pour tout ce que
je viens vous décrire évidemment il faut
consulter un médecin
et chose importante vous le comprenez
quand on court il faut avoir avec soi un
portable parce que parfois ça peut vous
sauver la vie
à bientôt pour un nouveau conseil
running